hey guys it is monday the 14th of april
today my name is jess mcdonald and you
are watching guess what news first up by
where have chatted about the new
generation consoles and why including
same-sex relationships in their games is
important to them while they aren't
confirming any details for the upcoming
installment mass effect writer Kathleen
roots art said inclusivity is part of
the Bioware mandate art director Joel
McMillan hinted that the title might
make its way to xbox one and ps4
explaining it's kind of tricky to
officially comment on that but I mean
gen4 looks pretty awesome and mass
effects an awesome looking game so far
but we know of the upcoming Mass Effect
game is that it'll run on dices
frostbite 3 engine and won't revolve
around Commander Shepard let us know in
the comments what you want out of the
next Mass Effect and if you think it
should come to new generation consoles
in these are things that are either
super weird or super awesome a
first-person soda drinking game is
coming to the Xbox one the allegedly
extremely advanced soda drinking
simulator which is already available
right now on PC with oculus rift support
and everything is set to launch on Xbox
one thanks to its developer will briley
signing up with Microsoft's independent
publishing initiative ID at Xbox the
game entitled soda drinker Pro is
planning to entice people to its Xbox
one version with more than 100
simulations as well as 10
never-before-seen exclusives there's
also connects support which apparently
allows players to truly feel the cup in
their hands as they grasp their soda and
drink it to infinity there are new game
modes including a hyper realistic
simulation mode as well as achievements
because that's a thing that makes sense
do you guys think this is in the same
vein as goat simulator or is it pushing
the silly envelope just a tad too far
last up today we've got the PC ultra
specs for watchdogs and expectedly
they're pretty damn high creative
director Johnathan Morin tweeted the
optimum CPU and GPU to meet the game's
ultra specifications and they come to an
intel core i7 4770k with the GeForce 780
he's also commented on the widely
praised p
see trailer that came out a short while
ago saying that it was running with a
core i7 3930k with a geforce titan not
only of these ultra specs significantly
higher than the recommended system
requirements but they're even higher
than the room at ultra specs for the
game which leaked last year let me know
if your pc is going to be able to run
watchdogs on ultra settings or not
either in that commenting section down
below or you can do so on my Twitter
where I'm at just McDonald those are all
the game you type things that I want to
tell you about today but join me same
time and place tomorrow for more stuff